thank you very much good afternoon
everybody
my name is Bowen mom minister of
Emergency Management and climate
Readiness and I'm honored to be here
today on the traditional territory of
the musqueam Squamish and sleiwototh
peoples
today we will be providing information
on Wildfire preparedness and the
Wildfire season outlook I'm pleased to
be joined by Bruce Ralston minister of
forests responsible for the BC Wildfire
service
Matt McDonald lead fire weather
forecaster with the BC Wildfire service
and Neil McLaughlin superintendent of
Predictive Services with the BC Wildfire
service we also have several other folks
on the line to help answer questions
that you may have
this week Canadians right across the
country have been impacted by wildfire
and smoke from wildfires
with heightened temperatures this week
and with Summer on our doorstep British
Columbians are understandably wondering
what the summer will be like in terms of
wildfire
this Wildfire season in British Columbia
is already well underway and has been
since mid-april
there are currently 82 wildfires burning
across the province and since April 1st
382 wildfires have burned a total of 520
520 hectares
already the number of hectares burned
this season exceeds the total number of
hectares burned in 16 of the last 20
Wildfire seasons
99 of this fire activity so far has been
within the Prince George fire Center
which includes Central and Northeastern
BC
more than one thousand Personnel have
been directly engaged in Wildfire
response efforts in the North Peace over
the last month
significant fires are also being
responded to in the coastal region of
the province
I know that this is a concerning time
for people who are impacted by the
highway foreclosure due to the Cameron
Bluff wildfire
please know that this closure is
temporary
a detour is in place but it should also
only be used for emergencies
we continue to ensure that people have
the essentials that they need trucks are
making it through the detour route there
is no need to stock up on essential
supplies we are asking people to stay
calm and purchase only what you need so
that everyone in your communities can
access the supplies that they require
let's continue to look out for each
other
I would like to thank the dedicated and
professional and expert staff members
from the BC Wildfire service for all of
their work to date and for their work to
come this season as well I want to
acknowledge the local fire departments
that often consist of volunteers for
their work in assisting to responding to
wildfires I would also like to thank
communities and Volunteers in evacuation
centers who have supported their
neighbors by administering BC's
emergency Support Services
as a reminder as of noon today campfires
are prohibited in most regions of the
province open burning fires also remain
prohibited across the entire province
please check prohibitions in your region
before lighting a fire of any kind you
can find this information on the BC
Wildfire Service website or mobile app
as we move further into the Wildfire
season I encourage and urge people to
stay informed and to be prepared
while our government is making sure
supports and resources are in place for
the upcoming Wildfire season it's
equally important that people start
putting together a plan
now is the time to understand the
hazards that you face in the regions
that you live in and to prepare
yourselves your family your Home and
Community for any potential fires
we need people to follow all fire bans
and avoid activity that may result in a
wildfire
whether you live near an active Wildfire
or not I encourage every British
Columbian to take 20 minutes out of your
day to put together an emergency plan
including packing a grab-and-go
emergency kit so that you are prepared
to leave immediately if you are required
to evacuate
your grab-and-go bag should include
important documents such as
identification and insurance papers and
I encourage everyone to review their
insurance policy for fire damage
in 2021 during the global pandemic
large-scale Wildfire evacuations
occurred during a time of Public Health
restrictions coupled with high vacancy
rates in hotels across the province
now we have seen a significant
resumption of travel and tourism which
means that hotels are not as widely
available as they were in 2021
as a result accommodation may look
different in the event of significant
evacuations with greater emphasis on
group lodging at community centers and
on billeting
my Ministry continues to work closely
with First Nations local authorities and
other partners to identify communities
and venues that can support evacuees in
the event of a large-scale evacuation
this Advanced planning will help keep
evacuees safe and as close to their
homes as possible
the event that you are evacuated you may
find it more suitable for you and your
immediate family to stay with family and
friends in a community that is safe from
wildfires it is worth making those
connections now and having those
conversations with family and friends in
other areas of the province early
I want to reassure you that if you
choose to stay with family and friends
you will still be eligible for emergency
Support Services if you require
assistance to help with costs related to
building food and incidentals
I want to emphasize that the province
First Nations and local authorities will
be there to assist All Families or
individuals who need accommodation or
assistance
last year our government provided
British Columbians with one more tool to
support them in preparing for a wildfire
or other disaster we made it possible
for people to pre-register with
emergency support services online using
the evacuee registration and assistance
tool
pre-registration means that evacuees
don't need to spend time signing up
while they are in an emergency so
individuals and families can
pre-register now at
ess.gov.bc.ca that's ess.gov.vc.ca
during emergencies The Province
amplifies all evacuation alerts and
orders issued by local communities on
emergency info BC and emergency info
BC's Twitter account
the BC Wildfire Service website social
media channels and the BC Wildfire
service mobile app which is available
for Apple and Android devices provides
the location and details of all active
wildfires in BC
this BC Wildfire Service app is also
where you can report a wildfire
during an emergency these platforms also
share advice and resources to help
people and communities stay safe The
Province may also issue broadcast
intrusive alerts for evacuations on
behalf of communities
it is important that British Columbians
are aware of these sources of
information before an emergency takes
place
we are seeing the impacts of climate
change all around us
climate-related emergencies are
increasing just last month we were
dealing with flooding in parts of the
province
disaster financial assistance is
available for eligible British
Columbians in southeast and Central
areas of the province who were affected
by flooding between April 27th and May
16th this year
we have also seen that heat events are
becoming more frequent and projected to
become more severe due to climate change
heat is now a part of our reality and it
is critical that British Columbians
understand what they can do to protect
themselves and their loved ones if these
events happen
our government has worked to improve
public education communication and
services during heat events this
includes launching the BC heat alert and
response system providing funding for
local governments to proactively open
cooling centers and provide
transportation for vulnerable people
supporting First Nations and local
authorities by introducing a new heat
extreme heat funding stream under the
Community emergency preparedness fund
and releasing the prepared BC extreme
heat preparedness guide so individuals
and families can take steps to prepare
during periods of hot weather make sure
you stay hydrated find cool or Shady
locations and check in on vulnerable
family members and Friends
I understand that heading into a
potentially hazardous Wildfire season
can be unsettling for people
but I want to assure British Columbians
that we are working hard to ensure
communities are prepared and have the
supports that they need in the event of
a wildfire or other climate-related
emergency
we urge individuals and families to take
the necessary steps to prepare by taking
steps to be prepared and knowing where
to find information we can all gain a
sense of control sense of safety and
peace of mind
be calm be alert be prepared this
Wildfire season let's enjoy the summer
but let's do it safely and with that I
will pass it on to minister Bruce
Ralston minister of forests
[Music]
um
and let me Begin by acknowledging all of
you that because fire and bicycle it's
extremely difficult that we did today
with smoke or near going in the 90s
I want to express my sincere thanks to
the firefighters First Responders
Emergency Management teams Highway Crews
and communities who are working hard
the recent Wildfire service is working
around the boxes of trust funders reduce
the impacts using share up-to-date
information without
several factors have been bound to raise
the concerns of confirm viruses we have
very dry Supreme across the process it
was the hottest paid offers resulting in
profits you know
the risk of funding has gone down but
the prospect of drug is very high
and
[Music]
forecast areas is specific concern for
potential wildfires these conditions if
they persist can impact our balance
fires grow and more aggressively they
burn lightning classifiers typically be
flavor of the song
we all proven being very appreciative of
the 2000 BC wildlife services now
dedicated to responding to the threat
posed by
the poster of course I want to thank you
for those workers and their families
supporting them through but it's already
a difficult for our season in parts of
our province
Investments
this the largest in our province's
history to strengthen Wildfire
preparedness from response most
important they move BC Wildfire service
a year-round operations
to boost our parents and planet
this year BC wildfires certified a
hundred huge amount of stuff and brought
up 330 new resources operating funds
we've invested in new structured
protection rules drones
Camp infrastructure it's massive water
increases
to assist with virus depression
we doubled the energy throughout our
prevention programs
BC weather stations have been operated
and Innovative technology is being
employed to support Predictive Services
and assist in preparedness
to capture and response but they're
still important to do
given recent history of knowing that
climate change will result in more
impactful bundles we will keep working
to boost the style and Equipment of the
BC Wildfire service
let me also recognize the work of First
Nations and local governments who have
already been responding to fires and
preparing their communities to be
wildfired women
thank you to all the BC community and
families who have undertaken or the work
required to become participated as far
as part of our community players all
communities producers through to
subscribe to that group
as we boost the capacity of the BC
wildfires we are also supporting the
efforts of local governments and First
Nations governments to prepare for fires
reduce Wildfire risks and respond fires
when they
when they occur in summary we continue
to aggressivars proactively
we continue to expel in our response to
the United States and provide a support
so at this point I'd like to turn it
over to obesity Wildfire service
personnel
thank you
good afternoon everyone and
well my name is Matt McDonald
and where we're heading I'm about to oh
you saw it
thanks First Nations people
so before we look out into the future
it's actually really practical to look
at where we've been and if you remember
about
in Fall of 20 and 22 it was a very dry
very warm October and believe it or not
that really set the stage for the 2023
Wildfire season in more recent memory uh
just having wrapped up the month of May
it was another record-breaking month
both in terms of heat and pronounced
drought and on your screen right now you
can see the temperature in all movies so
how cold or warm was it compared to
normal for the entire month of May as
you can see by the Sea of red across
western Canada it was an extremely warm
month in fact 16 communities across the
province of British Columbia set records
for the all-time hottest maid and many
of these records sending back to the
late 1800s very hot and additionally
very dry the image on the right hand
side speaks to diversification we
received through the lot thereof in the
Houston Brown speak to 80 or 90 less
specification than normal so very small
crops in a rather bucket
you know focusing a little bit more on
that heat it was truly exceptional and
it wasn't just a few days or even a
couple weeks it was really the entire
month of May a month which is to be cool
and showery in British Columbia was
actually very hot and uh and very dry as
an example here we pulled out the
temperatures of Williams Lake in the
Caribou fire Center and you can see that
each and every individual day we're
showing temperature anomalies so again
compared to historical averages that
were consistently five six and eight
even 10 degrees more than normal and
you'll notice that we only had two
little Zoo bars there uh in the third
week of May so very hot
and what this did is it accelerated the
curing of our fuels of our forest but it
also accelerated the Melt of our
snowpacks in the Alpine you know that
our obviously brought some concern from
a frechette point of view and we poured
this slide here from our colleagues at
River forecast Center
but I'll draw your attention to the
black line here that represents the the
rapid decline in the provincial
snowpacks as we headed through the month
of May so we shed that snow extremely
fast uh fortunately there wasn't too
much flooding but again what this did is
it made our fuels available to lightning
ignition so lightning typically strikes
in the Alpine at Ridge Top and once
those forests once those fuels are no
longer buried in fuel in snow rather
they become receptive to fuel so these
melted that snow three to four weeks
earlier than normal and
again as we approach the peak of
lightning season those fuels are ready
to be ignited
um
touching on the joke a little bit more
before I pass it over to my colleague
Neil McLaughlin you know there's many
different ways we can Define trout uh
there's drought from an agricultural
perspective there is trout from a
hydrological perspective and then of
course there's drought from a forest and
fuel perspective and uh this spring and
early summer we're all agreeing that uh
this this drought is widespread and uh
it's uh it's really persistent and the
image on the left hand side here shows
you the total amount of precipitation
compared to normal that we've seen since
March 1st over the last 90 days how much
rain has fallen across British Columbia
and you'll notice many Hues of yellow
and orange indicating drier than normal
conditions uh the one exception being
the southern peace which is actually
where we have our large fires that are
currently burning we of course have the
Timber Ridge fire through the North and
around Fort St John and then extending
all the way up to the very Northern
Northeastern Corner in Fort Nelson uh it
may seem surprising to see some green
there but we have to remember the
fashion in which this precipitation came
so we actually had a two-day Wonder of
heavy rainfall we uh we picked up 450
millimeters of rain and when we receive
rain in that type of fashion it doesn't
infiltrate the ground it doesn't help or
fuel as much it's too much in a short
period of time and uh really those fires
just kept burning only a couple
default another example I can point out
here is from Prince George in the center
part of the province where you know over
the past 90 days we typically would have
picked up around 115 120 millimeters of
rain and this year we only picked up
about half of that at 58 millimeters so
it just speaks to the Drone in not only
one or two pockets but really many
pockets of the province and uh to tell
you more about how the fuels have
responded to that I'll pass it over to
you know
who is our superintendent of Predictive
Services
thank you Matt so we're going to
continue the story here and look at how
these anti-student weather conditions
are going to show up in terms of the
plug environment and as well as in terms
of fire Behavior if we're observing this
this season so on this graph we're
looking at the buildup index this is a
measure of fuel availability and it's
composed of two moisture codes that
represent medium and core sized fuels as
well as the shallow and deep duct layers
of the soil as this index increases its
indicate
indicator and more available to burn
what you're seeing on this map is not
necessarily the index value that we
would calculate but how anomalous it is
time of year and so this graph
represents May 29th of 2023
and the colors of yellow into deeper
Reds are indicating above normal buildup
index values
what that means is that our fuels are
increasingly available to burn and and
more so than we could take SMG for this
time of year the other thing I'll draw
your attention to is that there are some
areas of white on the map uh in the
Southeast Corner
um
they're normal in there is nowhere on
this map that we're seeing anything
that's below normal for this time of
year so this amount is now 10 days old
and we've been drying a few
one more message about this uh this
slide these are very slow moving indices
and this morning didn't start in may
this year I think we saw elevated drugs
and
in the southwest corners of the province
last fall and we're carrying forward
several years of dry conditions that are
being further exacerbated by the weather
conditions that
so we'll move to the next slide and look
at some fire behavior and how these
conditions are are reflected on the
left-hand side we're looking at a
picture of the Donnie Creek
on May 26th and what's really
interesting is that this fire did
actually receive a fairly good amount of
precipitation 40 millimeters of rain
but in this picture what you're seeing
is that we had a subsequent 30 kilometer
fire run in in just five days after that
rain was received
received this fire is now well over 300
000 hectares of skies
on the right hand side we're looking at
a fire that's in our Coastal fire Center
Castle Creek Fire this photo was taken
recently on June 3rd and what you're
looking at is the the root bulb of a
large tree and the depth of burn I draw
your attention to the plotsky that's in
the foreground to handle on that that
philosophy is about in here in length
and so we're looking at a meter of fuel
consumption in the early Fire season
this might be typically a really dry
fall but
early May in June
very Anonymous and so you know why we
share these photos is
um you know one question we might get is
you know are you confident in in the
metrics that are reflective of the
expected fire Behavior and the best way
that we can have confidence is how that
reflects and fire behavior and so these
pictures are very much an indication or
metrics are a good indication of what we
can expect
great thank you Neil so uh Neil and I
have just set the stage for where we've
been where we currently sit and now
we'll shift gears and uh and look into
the future
um
you were fortunate to work very closely
with the the great meteorologists at
environment and climate change Canada
they recently issued their summer
outlook for 2023 and we'll start with
the top left image which is uh the
probabilistic chart for for June and
really what we're looking at here is not
necessarily the intensity of the heat
but the probability of three different
categories and so in Hues of orange and
red is high probabilities a bit warmer
than normal June and you can see that
right across western Canada as we shift
into July those Hues simmer down if you
like to about 40 or 50 percent so a
little less of a stronger signal and
then as we get into August that that
signal re-intensifies we get back into
those deeper oranges and so if we put
the three months together you get the
larger image which is the seasonal
outlook for temperatures for 2023 and as
you can see there's a fairly strong
signal right across the country for a
warmer than normal summer and these
long-term seasonal forecast need to be
taken with a grain of salt you know
right now we're very confident that this
current heat spell is going to end this
weekend we'll get into some more
seasonal weather next week but then we
have more heat on the way
uh from a precipitation perspective
again we'll start with the panel in the
top left corner there and as you can see
from the shades of brown uh we're
expecting a very dry June of course
we're already eight days through the
beginning of June uh we are expecting a
little bit of showers uh later on next
week but um you know given those drought
those persistent deep drought conditions
that Neil spoke to it's not going to be
enough rainfall to alleviate these deep
persistent drought conditions right
across the province I should emphasize
that unfortunately despite the
advancements in science the skill of
anything longer than perhaps a two-week
forecast from a rainfall perspective
just simply doesn't have too much skill
so we'll have to see what the remainder
of Summer will bring as we get into the
core of the true core of Fire season
which is July and August but suffice to
say that those are typically our driest
months and the the the possibility of
playing catch-up is is very limited
so going forward from this point uh we
thought it'd be helpful to lay out three
possible scenarios and we'll start with
the one on the left which is currently
what we're experiencing in across all of
British Columbia it's it's very hot
outside we're reaching the mid 30s again
today in the interior not only is it hot
but it's extremely dry we we really keep
close eye on relative humidities and
those have been down in the single
digits so when we get below 10 relative
humidity which we are currently doing
across a good chunk of the interior of
the province those are like desert-like
conditions and it just again accelerates
the drying of those fuels and
exacerbates the drought
um and as I mentioned you know we're
going to be in this pattern until the
weekend we see a pattern change which
unfortunately is going to be accompanied
by thunderstorms and strong winds will
not bode well for existing fires and
then may again initiate
um ignite new fires uh in the middle of
the screen we have kind of the normal uh
pattern and typically you know we get
beautiful summers in British climate
that's a lot of why a lot of us live
here and we usually see the The Ridge of
California that uh lives off the coast
move up off the coast of British
Columbia and so as even if a normal
pattern should play out we need to
remember that you know summer's in in BC
are warm and and typically pretty dry
and then the most unlikely scenario
right now is the one on the on the right
hand side which is uh the development of
a big upper trough or what we call an
upper low in these systems sometimes can
stagnate on place and you know deliver
those January type conditions that we
we've had in the past unfortunately
there's not really much indication of
that developing again we're going to
have a little blip in this heat in this
dryness next week which will be welcomed
by almost everyone but uh further on
into the latter half of June it looks
like we're back into scenario number one
there
so with that I'll pass it back to Neil
to talk about lightning season and wrap
up her presentation thank you
thanks Matt
um so a little bit more about lightning
uh in the lower left graphic we're
looking at the typical time of year that
our lightning season begins and
throughout most of the the province of
British Columbia which is highlighted in
in a bold black outline uh we're seeing
that we typically see lightning start in
the later part of May and really pick up
in uh in the month of June and and
through the rest of the summer and so
that's when it starts
um this is important because as Matt
mentioned earlier we've melted all our
snow and we've got more land area
available to ignite due to lightning
caused ignitions than than typically uh
we would at this time of year as we look
at the graph on the right this is just
showing by month uh the proportion of
our fires that are caused by human
activity unknown causes or lightning and
so I draw your attention to the the
darker Shades of Gray along the bottom
they remain fairly stable you know
between 75 100 starts per month
throughout the whole Fire season but
when we look at lightning we see a very
upward Trend as we shift into May
whereas you know lightning season is
starting picks up in June and and our
busiest months are then July and August
where we can see upwards of 250 to 300
fire uh lightning cause fires per month
and so you know when you do the math on
that the number of fires we're seeing
per week it's a lot to keep up to
um what we're most concerned about this
year as as I mentioned earlier with snow
melt uh now uh in our in in our past uh
we could be seeing even more ignitions
earlier uh you know three to four weeks
earlier in the month of June uh so those
patterns that Matt was just sharing you
know one of our big concerns is the rate
at which we see these lightning events
occur and so you know we could get uh
scattered lightning and uh and a slow
Pace or we could see a big weather
system change that brings a widespread
lightning all at once and and those are
very concerning situations to fire
agencies where there's more fire than
than we may be able to respond to
um and when we've got you know fuels
available to burn and potentially uh
associated with with fast wind speeds
it's a very challenging situation for
fire agencies we'll move to the next
slide and look at one more uh fire
Behavior indicator and how that's
reflecting this fire season so these
graphs are showing you our drought code
value this is uh reflective of our
slowest moving moisture code the the
largest size fuels the deepest Duff
layers and our current fire season is is
the large map on the left hand side and
as you see the colors of yellow into
orange those are indicating very high
levels of drug condition or low fuel
moisture and our largest size possible
they take a very long time to recharge
with moisture and when we look across
the last six years for this time of year
we're seeing a very different pattern on
the landscape and I I do want to mention
that of those last six years three of
them are are some of the larger fire
seasons in BC's uh recent history
we've included some hectors burned by
that time of year June 6th for each of
those historical reference points and
you know where we're sitting this year
at well over 450 000 hectares far
exceeds any of those previous years and
so quite alarming to see this amount of
area burning this early in the season
and it certainly doesn't bode well for
the remainder of this the Summer with
the uh the Outlook that Matt has shared
so we'll move into some closing points
for our summer Outlook
I'd really like to leave you with some
key takeaways
um you know we've we've I think
articulated several different ways that
our fuels are available to burn and
there's really kind of three key
ingredients when it comes to uh you know
extreme fire Behavior one is that fuels
are available to burn two is that we
have strong winds and three you know the
key ingredient that I just finished
speaking to you about is that we get
ignitions and so uh when we put the
three of those together it's it's a very
challenging Fire season outlook
um high elevations are currently snow
free and so we are expecting that
lightning season will start earlier in
fact we're already seeing early signs of
that with with Fires at upper elevations
burning quite aggressively
uh the sustained warm conditions that
Matt spoke to in terms of the summer
Outlook are going to further exacerbate
uh fuel availability but with that that
comes the risk of thunderstorms and
potential wind events as we see these
weather patterns shift which will
escalate fire load and challenge our
fire suppression capacity
now nationally we tend to leverage uh
resource sharing agreements with our
partnering agencies and when we're in
need we can call on them for help I'm
sure a lot of you have been watching the
news or hearing news clips about the
national situation all agencies across
Canada are busy this year and there is a
real shortage of resources for sharing
and so this could be a year where we
have to really dig deep and use the
resources we have here in BC to address
our situation so uh my my parting
message and what I really want to make
clear to everyone is that it's more
important than ever to be responsible
with permitted fire use and extremely
cautious with any activity that could
spark a wildfire uh wildfire
prohibitions and restrictions are
already in place for most of the
province and we should expect that
they'll continue throughout most of the
fire season as our fire hazard continues
to go up and we are challenged by the
fire situation
so with that I'm going to pass it back
to minister ma as we move into our
question period thank you
impacting people all across the country
people are confirm British Columbians
are concerned about wildfires here and
we are certainly anticipating a
challenging season ahead but I do want
to assure British Columbians that our
government is doing everything necessary
to make sure that the proper supports
and resources are in place for the
upcoming season at the same time it is
vitally important that every member of
our community our Collective Community
every individual every household
be prepared for what is coming as well
start putting together a plan get your
grab-and-go kit together stay informed
stay calm be alert be prepared and with
that I welcome questions for our team
thank you very much a reminder to media
on the line please press star one to
enter the queue for the opportunity to
ask a question and a follow-up thank you
very much everyone for bearing with us
as we faced some audio visual challenges
for this availability I will also note
that we have additional speakers on the
line who are available to answer
questions should they pertain to their
subject matter expertise we are going to
start in the room we'll hear first from
Lauren Collins block press Lauren please
go ahead hi based on the comments about
the situation Countrywide is BC looking
into more International resources to
plan ahead
so British Columbia earlier in the
Wildfire season did deploy some teams
over to Alberta we are calling them back
here to British Columbia within the next
few days we are putting in requests for
additional resources and getting in line
for some of those International
resources as well I'll also pass it on
to minister Ralston and his team over at
the BC Wildfire service to provide
further comments
great thank you very much some of you
will have noted that today President
Biden spoke with prime minister Trudeau
and offered the support of the American
Wildfire service there's a similar
pooling agency that pools national
resources in the United States and so I
would turn it over to either Neil or
Matt or Chris I think is also on the
line to talk a little bit further about
that
yeah thank you Minister Ralston uh my
name is Cliff Chapman I am the director
of provincial operations for BC Wildfire
service and it's uh thank you for your
question about international support so
we have a request in to uh see the
Canadian interagency forest fire Center
uh that manages Canadian resources
that's how we did deploy resources to
Alberta earlier in the spring and we
have a request in uh multiple requests
in actually with sipsy to seek
additional support for BC not so much
for the next 72 hours we still have
resources available in BC as we speak
today but it's really about trying to
plan for the next two three five weeks
so we have requested for right now it's
summer in the neighborhood of 200 staff
to come and support our firefighting
efforts from ground resources to
firefighting resources all the way up to
Incident Management teams to support our
efforts in BC as we continue to see fire
on the landscape in our province
Lauren do you have a follow-up
look like in BC right now I know there's
provinces or fires throughout the
province on the island up in the north
Southeast
will stay with you you probably have the
numbers on that
sorry the question came through broken
can I get the question again
yes what do the resources look like
throughout the province I know there's
fires on the island the Northeast the
southeast ongoing right now
so resourcing right now as it pertains
to British Columbia and you heard
Minister Ralston talk about our uplift
that we've seen over the last 12 months
as we continue to evolve as an
organization a 12-month of the Year
Organization for better preparedness so
we have resources engaged really from
north to south and east to west and some
of those resources we would say they're
on preparedness so they are essentially
waiting for the call for new fires
should we receive any and we call that
our initial attack and then we have
obviously thousands up just over a
thousand people engaged right now on our
current fires so from the Northeast
predominantly uh is where many of our
resources are but we also have seen a
ship where we've started to send
resources to the island uh and it
continue to ensure that we have
resources across the province for those
new starts you know our best chance of
success as we continue through whatever
this fire season may bring is to really
Surge and focus on initial attack when
we first see a fire when we first get a
report of fire to really attack that
fire as aggressively as we can from the
air from the ground and with crew
resources and again I would urge the
public that's why we continue to urge
the public to download our mobile app to
to know the numbers start by 555 on your
cell phone if you see smoke even if you
think it's been replaced please call it
in if it is a repeat smoke it's good for
us because it allows us the ability to
really surge to those initial new starts
and if it's an existing fire that's okay
we'll know that from our mapping and our
GIS so so please let us know if you see
smoke in the landscape
our next question also comes from the
room we'll hear from Seth forward Globe
and Mail Seth please go ahead
um is there any threat to infrastructure
currently and what is the plan to deal
with those threats this summer
well certainly there are always uh there
are always potential threats to
infrastructure depending on the hazard
that we are facing
um it I I would say that it's probably
too early to guess where those impacts
are going to be but I open up the floor
to to the team if anyone wants to
comment on it now I mean certainly
Highway 4 is already impacted uh
um not well maybe Janelle actually uh
stop talking now Janelle who maybe you
can speak a little bit about Highway 4
and and what the impacts there are there
right now
absolutely thank you minister so right
now we do have Highway 4 on Banker
Island closed between Port Alberni and
Highway 19 and with that closure what we
are seeing is as a result of the fire we
have material and debris upslope of the
fire that is actually coming down onto
the highway so LBC Wildfire services are
fighting the fire we're also monitoring
the fire from the air from a
geotechnical perspective so once that
fires out we can assess any upslope
damage we can make sure that any danger
trees or any Boulders are mitigated
prior to reopening the highway at this
point we have seen trees and boulders
come down onto the highway but those
have not actually impacted the physical
Integrity of the highway
thank you Janelle and and I think in
addition to the highway impacts uh we
have been dealing with Community
potential Community impacts really since
the middle of April so there's been
evacuation alerts and orders for
communities in Mitchell cotton for
communities across the bridge George
fire Center and now we're starting to
see that as it's shipped to the South so
we are likely to see continual uh Evac
orders and alerts as Fire season uh
presses on and in terms of our strategy
uh on what we do that that is really how
we prioritize
fires in the Pro
G looking to surge our resources to the
most viable uh or the highest priority
fires it is about what are the what are
the potential impacts and uh just as
we're speaking today we're hearing of a
potential impact up in the Northeast and
not impacting a community directly but
potentially expanding an evacuation
order and as you've seen through the
wildfires of note and I encourage folks
to look at the wildfires and note to to
get an update on where our fires are at
as well as Associated ebac alerts and
orders that is where the information is
housed on the DC wildfire.ca website so
we will continue to see that and and it
is part of the investment that Minister
Ralston spoke about was an increase in
our structured protection and structured
defense capacity the ability for us to
send the right resources working with
the local government and First Nation
government and volunteer as well as
structural fire departments to go and
deploy sprinklers to go and set up water
lines so that we can do everything in
our power to protect homes and protect
communities should a fire be approaching
them so that that's something that's
been a significant investment over the
last couple of years and and we have
some of our own technology now that we
can deploy onto fires such as the ones
in the north right now
you have a follow-up Seth yeah would you
ever would you be able to put a number
on the funding for uh infrastructure
um like preparedness or like keeping
that number down right I mean what we
know in the Emergency Management world
what we know is that an ounce of
prevention is worth a pound of cure
every dollar that we spend on
Preparation and mitigation mitigating
impacts of disasters before they happen
is worth potentially a order of
magnitude in terms of response and
Recovery costs and we saw how how much
impact has been caused by previous
Wildfire Seasons as well as the
atmospheric River events as well the
create with the creation of the new
ministry of Emergency Management and
climate Readiness is a renewed focus and
effort on those prevention and
mitigative efforts so we for instance
have the community emergency
preparedness fund that is that was
recently topped up with an additional
180 million dollars on top of a
previously allotted 189 million dollars
that is funding that is provided to
communities and local like local
governments and First Nations to support
them and their mitigation efforts
certainly different Ministries also have
their mitigative efforts as well for
instance when it comes to seismic
hazards Ministry of Education and child
care are doing seismic upgrades Ministry
of Transportation also has a seismic
program that there have underway since
the ministry of Emergency Management
climate Readiness was created we have
announced over just our ministry over a
quarter of a billion dollars in
investments in mitigation efforts to
funding for local governments and
communities but that is not all that we
are doing we also recognize that it's as
big of a number as it might sound right
now it's scratching the surface of what
needs to be done there's a lot of work
ahead of us right across the government
and for the next question we are going
to the phones our first question from
the phones comes from Richard zissman
Global News Richard please go ahead
um I believe that that is a question for
the BC Wildfire service
Richard are you able to repeat your
question just so we can hear it here on
the zoom we weren't able to pick it up
apologies we still can't hear your
question over Zoom would we be able to
get the question was about how this
Wildfire season uh Compares with
historic Wildfire Seasons Wildfire
seasons in the past and is this likely
to the question was whether this was
likely to be the worst Wildfire season
that we have experienced in the province
is that right Richard
[Music]
thank you it's probably a BC Wildfire
service question
thank you for the question uh you know I
think this is something that we get
asked quite frequently is how does this
season stack up to past Seasons you saw
from uh Neil and Matt's presentation how
we've stacked up to date and and I think
it wouldn't be going out on a limb to
say that this has been one of the the
most challenging Wildfire Seasons to
date uh so from the beginning of April
until June 8th it has been very
challenging and the numbers represent
that we're seeing really on our 10-year
average we would see roughly 20 000
hectares of fire on the landscape at
this time at this point in the year and
those include 2017 2018 and 2021 uh
three of the most challenging fire
Seasons BC has ever faced so uh 20 000
hectares is our 10-year average and
we're at just over half a million
hectares burned so far this spring so
hard to forecast whether or not it will
be as uh challenging as some of the
seasons in the past in the past 17 18
and 2021 but I would say as we saw
through the forecast today with Matt and
Neil that I think first Colombians BC
Wildfire service communities First
Nation communities we all have to be
prepared that this season is going to be
very challenging or has the potential to
be uh certainly the variables are lining
up in such a way that if we don't see
significant precipitation significant
rain uh happen across the province that
we will be carrying hazards the other
ingredient though is going to be starts
ignition sources and as we know and Neil
and Matt spoke to we are just entering
into our lightning season and with the
prohibitions in place we should see a
reduction in human-cost buyers but we
can't control the lightning-caused fires
obviously so so you know it doesn't
answer your question directly I would
suggest that as British Columbia we need
to be prepared that this is going to be
a very challenging Fire season
thank you very much uh Richard we'll
give it a go for the follow-up please
proceed
and Minister are you able to repeat the
question as we're not able to hear it on
Zoom
I was there and just because I know that
we're having some technical challenges
uh your latter question Richard was
about
um the campfire ban and uh basically
what's to to come of that whether it's
going to be in place for the entire
summer how it how we anticipate it
changing whether it expands or contracts
and your first question was probably a
question to Janelle's state of Ministry
of Transportation infrastructure about a
detour route with and then I didn't
quite catch it I take it as a Highway 4
detour route can you maybe repeat that
part
the problems
thank you said Mosaic Forest management
four-lane detour route is that right
Horn Lake Road okay is it
Janelle maybe that
yeah thanks minister so we have
yesterday opened a detour route between
Port Alberni and Lake Cowichan we've
been working closely with private
industrial roads as well as Forest
Service Roads so that detour route is is
gravel it is narrow it has some some
challenging segments but certainly for
folks that are essential Services they
can travel through their people who have
an essential need to travel commercial
Goods to make sure that goods and
amenities are getting to and from the
West Coast it's working very well we
have had some people approach us about
the possibility of working with Mosaic
to open the Horn Lake connector as it's
called locally
that connects Highway 4 back through
Horn Lake a little bit to the north and
intersects with Highway 19 just north of
Qualicum we've been chatting with Mosaic
about that and for very specific
Vehicles we are using this road
um with the permission of Mosaic so
emergency services at the request of
Mosaic are able to get through there we
have some critical BC Wildfire Services
Personnel getting through there as well
as Ministry maintenance contractors
getting through there this is the
singling Road it only enables traffic to
get through if it's piloted it cannot
handle commercial vehicles and it needs
4x4 vehicles to get through there so
it's certainly not an an
all-encompassing detour route but one
that is being used very specifically for
high-need vehicles along the way but as
I said the detour route that we have
operating on industrial roads and Forest
Service Roads between Port Alberni and
lake cowajin is working very effectively
at this point
I'll address your
account I think it's worth recognizing
that this is and don't quote me on this
but I believe this is the earliest we've
seen essentially a provincial wide
campfire prohibition come in this early
uh as we've heard and we all know it's
it's June 8th uh kids are still in
school the camping season is it's just
beginning and we recognize the you know
that people enjoy having campfires
saying that uh we're obviously putting
this prohibition on for a reason the
conditions are such that we believe we
really cannot afford to have human-cost
fires uh we heard the update on resource
drive across Canada if we reflect back
on the national pitcher for the
three-month seasonal Outlook the entire
country is in queues of rent so the
forecast right now is that all of Canada
will see hotter and drier conditions for
the summer months so what that means is
there'll be less opportunity for us to
lean into our partner agencies Alberta
Saskatchewan Ontario Etc to have support
to to fight buyers that are in BC uh so
I am not saying that campfire bands will
be on for the duration of the summer but
I also am not saying that they they
won't be I think it's something that we
take very seriously in BC Wildfire
service trying to balance the needs of
the public with the operational demand
and fuel conditions that are happening
on the landscape so if we see
significant rainfall uh we may start to
pull campfire prohibitions off if we
continue to see hot and dry conditions
and fires on the landscape we we will
likely keep the prohibition on and
that's something that we can obviously
take it off and then put it back on
again and that's something that we're
always conscious of so
in terms of this the length and time
that the prohibitions will be will be a
place it's too soon to answer that
question but I think we need to be
prepared that if we don't see rain that
prohibitions will remain in place for
the foreseeable future
thanks very much Cliff we're going to go
to the next question from the phones I'm
going to be listening on another line
and if it is repeating I will do that
we'll go to mirabane CBC Mira please go
ahead
thanks very much okay so Mira is asking
what areas Neil or Matt are you most
concerned about in The Province perhaps
for lightning strikes or in general
Wildfire risk
foreign
yeah great question
um as we speak there there are actually
thunderstorms that are entering the
southeast corner of the province and uh
or fire weather forecaster for the
southeast fire Center just recently
issued a thunderstorm warning uh again
because our fuels are so receptive right
now to ignition and uh this first round
of thunderstorms entering the southeast
corner so we're talking in around the
Fernie elkford area is expected to
spread Westward through the evening
through Cranbrook out towards Castlegar
and then even potentially as far west as
a soyuz and the southern Okanagan so
this is a first round of thunderstorms
uh that pattern persists in through
tomorrow fortunately tomorrow's
thunderstorms will likely be accompanied
by some rain uh very spatially diverse
so it's going to be spotty uh it could
pick up anywhere from two millimeters to
20 millimeters but there are going to be
areas that actually don't get any
rainfall at all and then you know as we
even get into Saturday that that signal
for in stability and additional
thunderstorms persist and actually
extends right through to Northern BCE so
all up and down the Rockies into that
very dry northeast corner we're
anticipating isolated lightning strikes
on Saturday as well so we're gonna have
to see until we get through Saturday uh
just how much lightning we pick up right
now the highest concentration is
definitely the southeast Corner
expanding Westward and northwards
tomorrow on Friday and then right up to
the northern border with the Yukon come
Saturday
um
into next week we're looking at a
quieter what we call a Westerly flow
pattern so a little a lot more seasonal
we're going to return to seasonal
temperatures we may pick up some much
needed showers and then beyond that you
know I'd love to be able to forecast
lightning out through July and August
but uh that's just not possible
and we'll go to Neil McLaughlin next
yeah thank you just to add to Matt's
comments there
um
we have a couple different moisture
indices that we track and one of them
gives us the Insight in terms of
holdover ignition you are now rejoining
the main conference most of the province
is uh available to uh lightning ignition
with the exception of the far northwest
corner of the province unfortunately we
don't get to choose where lightning
strikes I think one of the things we're
most concerned about is large events
that bring lightning close to uh
communities and and human values and so
um that's that's the trick is is we
don't have a choice in that but uh you
know really there's concern across most
of the province and it'll be a matter of
tracking storm systems as they
materialize in terms of where that that
could occur and if it's close to
communities that could be problematic I
think I want to emphasize what I shared
earlier it's it's not so much lightning
it's the pace at which we get starts and
so if we get a large widespread
lightning event that brings a
thank you
okay we're going to go to the next I'm
not going to quickly overcome our
capacity to respond Chris
all right another technical issue with
the zoom there we are going to move to
the next question from the phones we
heard from Joe rutle Vancouver's son Joe
please go ahead
Joe has left the meeting
thank you very much we are going to go
to Michelle bernoro from CTV Michelle
please go ahead
hi there thanks for taking my question
um we've heard a bit about the lightning
cause fires I'm wondering if you can
tell me how many fires are suspected to
be human cause this year and given the
challenging conditions how much of a
concern that is this summer as well
Cliff like I'm guessing that's a you
question as well
thank you minister so yeah we do have
the breakdown uh obviously in the spring
as we entered into April May June uh
where we are now the majority of our
fires are human cause
whether that's you know backyard burning
landscape level Burning uh uh with
industry and at times campfires and
other fire use activities so the
breakdown to date is we've had uh
roughly 240 of our fires have been human
caused uh 132 of our fires have been
lightning caused Which is higher than
normal for this time of year and we're
picking most of the fires we're picking
up now are lightning caused fires and
then there's a handful of fires that are
still under investigation with our fire
origin and college team in terms of the
concern through the next next two three
months you know that is really why we
have the ability to put fire
prohibitions in place uh we put the fire
or category two and three prohibitions
in I believe it was two weeks ago and
that's to limit that backyard burning
that industrial burning and now we're
taking the the I would say for this time
of year unconventional step of putting
campfire prohibitions in in place as
well
I I will say the one thing about British
Columbians is that we are we're working
through this together over the last five
six years as fire has become a sort of a
main problem a main challenge for this
province to face there is there's far
more care being taken out in on the
landscape when we're when we are
introducing choirs so I do not suspect
it to be a challenge over the next three
months in particular as we have
prohibitions in place but also giving
the public some credit for using fire
with with care uh and being careful with
how they utilize fire and so we have
seen we've seen that over the last
couple of years is a decrease in in
human caused fires because there is more
care in British Columbia as we all face
these challenging fire Seasons together
Michelle do you have a follow-up
uh yes I do I'm not sure if you would
have this information handy but do you
have any idea roughly how many hectares
have burned this year and fires that
were human caused
I don't have that number uh directly
right in in front of me but I'm happy to
get that number back to you
um through uh through our event
coordinator
thank you very much and our last
question today comes from Brianna
Charlotte Canadian press Rihanna please
go ahead
uh great thanks so much I'm just curious
if we have the idea when you anticipate
Highway 4 to reopen
you have a an estimate on that
thank you minister so as we say we have
been working closely with BC Wildfire
services to understand the status of the
fire so at this point
um for for the safety of those folks who
are fighting the fire as well as the
safety of ministry staff it remains
closed when the fire is at a stage where
we're able to get our staff in there and
our contractors in there we we're on
standby to do that to get to the upslope
to be able to assess the hazards above
the trees the boulders to make sure
there's no risk of that coming down onto
Highway 4 which is a an extreme risk to
the traveling public so working very
closely to make sure there is no delay
in that time frame but at this point no
time frame in terms of its reopening
do you have a follow-up Brianna
oh yeah thanks so much I'm just sort of
wondering if the fire is also a threat
to Cathedral Grove and if so what's
being done to protect it
I will pass that question over to BC
Wildfire services
at this time uh the fire is not a direct
to uh Cathedral Grove obviously it's
early uh we're continuing to Surge
response resources to that fire
including aircraft uh air tank air
tanker resources to to really try to to
box it in where we have optimal ground
uh so at this point in time no uh but
that doesn't mean that things can't
change depending on the weather over the
course of the next number of days and
that's why we continue to try to surge
as many resources as we can where it's
safe to do so it's Steep and Rocky
terrain on that fire that you know that
doesn't stop us but we have to find uh
actionable ground for heavy equipment
for our air tanker operations and our
helicopter operations but I sure I
assure you that our staff are there and
they're doing everything they can to
contain that fire in a manageable box
what we're also trying to deal with the
challenges of the highway
thank you very much everyone that
concludes today's availability have a
good afternoon